je vais te demander à la Régie de mettre
le premier indice pour toi
la régie est toujours
elle est partie chez nous
bonjour Cyril je suis le premier indice
quoi
je suis le premier indice en fait il va
y avoir des séquences pourries tous les
soirs
[Rires]
aujourd'hui il y a des Gaspards
en plus
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez la difficulté de ce que je
vis voici l'état de l'appart à 18h02
donc ça apparemment c'est pas un lit
pour Redouane c'est une armoire
puisqu'il range ses affaires dessus ici
évidemment il laisse traîner quelques
petites affaires au cas où j'ai oublié
qu'il habite avec moi ça ça s'appelle un
slip sale de Redouane alors la technique
est très simple si tu veux pas que tes
doigts fondent en l'attrapant et bien tu
passes par dessus comme ça voilà c'est
une technique qu'on peut apprendre
j'allais dire là on peut remarquer que
Redouane apparemment est rentré du foot
aujourd'hui hein et alors ce qui est
bien avec lui hmm c'est que vraiment il
laisse les saveurs s'imprégner dans les
tissus ça c'est son petit déj de ce
matin pain au chocolat quoi évidemment
il a une alimentation équilibrée le
bougre et ça c'est ce qui va avec le
maillot de foot c'est à dire
toutes ces affaires dégueulasses qui
puent dans l'entrée voilà donc Redouane
je te l'annonce tes affaires vont aller
faire un joli petit tour je te fais pas
un dessin s'ils sont dans des jolis
petits sacs comme ça parce qu'ils vont
aller rencontrer Madame la poubelle mon
grand allez merci
à toi alors c'est pas vrai on s'est fait
cambrioler c'est pas vrai c'est
vraiment un fils de [__]
tu vas pouvoir lui dire il va venir en
direct
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va mon chéri
danser tout ça Redouane il a cassé
l'ambiance reparti regarde ça qu'est-ce
qui se passe alors non mais c'est bien
qu'on en parle parce que Redon ça fait
quoi ça fait un an et demi qu'on vit
ensemble à peu près quand il a à Londres
avec sa femme quand il apparaît il vit
avec moi et je le connais depuis bien
avant qu'il soit l'humoriste à succès
l'homme qui remplit des salles mais ce
soir je suis pas là pour parler de
l'artiste je suis là pour parler de
l'homme enfin du port
je te cache pas Redouane que j'en peux
plus de tes merdes qui traînent à la
Maison de la journée en plus toi tu sais
on n'est pas en train de rire là là ce
que tu as vu tu es parti de la part
parce que je te le dis il me dit ouais
c'est bon j'ai le temps et tout moi je
sais que je vais à la mission j'ai très
haut dépêche-toi accélère parce que je
pouvais pas dire pourquoi il me dit ça
va tranquille il commence à faire un
défilé il pose ses affaires par terre
bien ça ni no t'aime bien ça donc
maintenant je te le dis c'est simple tu
ranges soit moi je commence à être
plutôt côté dans le game des Colocs la
dernière Daniel qui m'a proposé une
petite
mais que moi elle a monté escalier Stana
donc le message il est clair et douane
soit dessus range mais tu t'engages
maintenant devant les gens à ranger
vraiment la partie
mais frérot j'ai pas le temps j'arrive
je vais spectacle foot mais je suis pas
ta femme
chronique dans la journée pas le temps
pour faire le ménage la journée
[Rires]
par contre je te dis je peux plus jamais
de surprise là c'est vrai pourquoi parce
que je suis assez d'habitude quand
j'arrive on va rigoler dans salon on
tape des barres et tout là je suis
arrivé la pro du mois rattrapé va te
cacher par la personne reste tout seul
enferme-toi j'ai l'impression d'être
Gilles Verdez plus jamais
[Applaudissements]
je
pars je dois aller jouer au théâtre tu
sais merci pour l'accueil
de mars je fais l'Olympia c'est
l'anniversaire de ma mère voilà
et moi toi après l'émission le spectacle
je te dis que ta mère
[Applaudissements]